Oh, here we go. Okay. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab and today, uh,
with me is Simon Adler. That's me.
He's a reporter and producer here and he's got us a tale. I do, uh,
it's an American tale and a kind of timely one, I think.
How would you describe it?
I think it's one of those classic us versus them tails or back,
or maybe it's an US versus us story in it. It's w
totally. I liked that more because I, in fact,
it takes place right in America's heartland.
We're in the heartland, Nebraska, Seneca, Nebraska,
this tiny little town in central West Nebraska. Okay.
It's near the town of mole in Nebraska, which, you know,
obviously also don't know. Yeah, no, that doesn't help me at all. So a,
this is Matthew Hanson. He is a reporter with the, with the Omaha World Herald.
And a couple months back he got in touch with us, uh, because he,
he had a story about this town, right?
So I got an email from a woman who lives a couple miles outside of town.
She was really upset because back in 2014, uh,
the town was split in half and in fact there was a group of people in the town
who were circulating a petition,
a petition that would end the town w circulate a petition to end the town.
Yeah. They didn't want to be a town anymore. Right. Really? Yeah. You know,
by law, if you have enough signatures on a petition,
you can get things on the ballot,
and the question that ended up on the ballot was,
should Seneca cease to exist
and this split, but let a group of people to try to end their own town.
It got us thinking about the split. That seems to be this election right now.
It occurred to us that maybe just maybe this tiny little town in the middle of
Nebraska might have something to say about the rest of us.
Well, let's back up then. So when,
when did all was well in Seneca until what?
It started with the horses. The horses. Okay. What,
what are these stories there? There were six horses. Actually, let me step back.
There were a lot of horses in Seneca. Most people in Seneca ride horses,
mini owned them. Um,
but there were these six particular horses right in the middle of town.
And you know, the, the split sort of started,
uh, right there.
So I got so curious about what went down in Seneca that I flew to Denver.
One, two, three, four, five,
drove five and a half hours into the sand hills of west Central Nebraska.
Let's see if we can get anything on the radio here.
These rolling sand dunes covered in grass that they ranch catalog.
There's another ranch. What's this one say?
And Smack Dab in the middle of the sandhills
is Seneca. After many hours and many miles we are here. Okay.
So uh, got these rolling hills that are
green dotted with these yellow flowers.
A junction 86, eight Seneca. Okay. We've got kind of an old,
bigger red sign that says welcome Seneca with a big red line. Okay.
And you get there. It looks like starting to drive through town,
a picture postcard, small town from yesteryear
down like railroad
tracks to our [inaudible] who's got the railroad. I'm taking a left,
I mean really pretty to my right,
an abandoned house to my left, another boarded up house,
another street with absolutely nothing on it. An old gas station.
It's all boarded up.
Another rundown house that says no trespassing and just really tiny,
I think went into the other is one eighth of a mile and we're done. Uh,
so there you go. At 30 miles per hour, it takes 10 seconds.
Okay. Turning around and wow. Okay. Um,
the house to the left here has a giant board over one of the windows that and
spray painted on it is sandy h is a big fat liar.
Interesting.
And so I ended up just walking through this tiny town of Seneca.
You're like knocking on every door.
I think I may have knocked on every single door in the town. Oh yeah. Yeah.
And of course I ended up talking to some folks who wanted to end the town,
others who wanted to save it and, and uh,
first up Judith Brown's house and she told
her notes to me were come down hill.
First House is nice.
That's not me burnt up yard. I don't know if this is it.
How are you this morning? Well, now that it's morning,
now you're here in New York City and how do you do it?
Very good to meet you. Everyone told me I can't let you into my house,
but I don't have any other way to cope with it. I'm not worried about.
And you want to plug in? No, I'm good. I'm all set here.
Oh good. Tell me who else you're going to talk to. Larry ISOM.
Oh, okay. Well, ELLs and Jackie. Severe.
Okay. I'm the sanest person you're going to talk to today.
Just so you know. That's what I,
the terrible thing to say.
I'm sorry about the cigarettes.
I want to get into more a contemporary things,
but real quickly to set the stage,
when did Seneca pop up on the map? Well,
all I know is when I was a little kid. It was a booming town. What would you do?
Well,
I mean they had great dances and wonderful bands and beer and there was no place
else to go. I mean, Santa Fe used to be really,
really fun, but okay. Well, so let me tell you the story.
Some people had come and they bought a house in Seneca.
Okay. This would have been fine. Except they have all these animals.
Nobody knows these people and there is a big fuss about them and their abusive.
These animals, there's sure animals are being abused.
See, I was under the impression that this was all about horses in a front yard.
Is that true?
They had horses. They had six horses in their backyard.
[inaudible]
that's the yard.
So we're talking like six horses in this size of a one car garage. Exactly.
Do you remember the first time you saw the horses here was all him or smelled?
Yeah, both at the same time. Larry Eisen,
former member of the town board.
I mean it's pretty hard to miss when you drive down the street when there's six
blocks to the town, you know that's, it's easy to to hear about things.
You, you'll be on the list also tomorrow. Oh really?
Am I going to be in Midland? Probably all have.
I'll have five phone calls on my phone at home by the time I get there.
And how did you decide that you were going to take this up as a cause?
As a member of the town board because of the complaints that were called to my
house. What are you going to do about the horses? Their,
they're up to their knees in excrement. What are you going to do about it?
And so you pass, you wrote an ordinance or, yeah. And what,
what did the ordinance set? I don't remember. It was two pages but,
but in any case it,
it stipulated a certain amount of square footage per horse as well as shelter
[inaudible]
well that was part of it.
The thing about Seneca is there's always a war in Seneca
again. Judith Brown. Okay.
Six horses in the front yard where the most concrete thing,
but Larry ICM and the bats you're going to go see?
They have always wanted us to look more like a cute little Colorado tourist
town. Wait, are we talking like beautification? Like less? Yes.
They wanted to create rules to create growth and I think they wanted to keep us
lower class people in line.
And so they were out here telling us what to do and they'll tell you things
about me.
Judah, she did the 60s in New York,
you've lived in a commune for time and Brenda brain down to save Seneca three
isom again. No, go. Nancy Isom, his wife and here Jackie. Severe.
So we don't want to defend, we don't want to bicker. No,
we don't want to open that up.
The ordinances were,
were necessary because of the situation that we were presented with.
There was no elite TISM.
They weren't on that board to dictate to anybody in this town.
They needed cabinets for the horses.
That's where you started and then you had people that was trying to say,
you're not going to tell me.
If you look around the little town,
you'll see the ones that take pride in what they have. I'm sorry,
but you that the debate.
So the town was split into,
I mean we could have liked each other,
but we've had nothing but constant, constant fighting.
Hello. Hi. Okay. She Ron, are you well, what's, what's the dogs name? Yes.
Presley. I'm Simon. I it that come on in also wanted to save the town up.
Asked her last name, not be used. Excited.
I mean I've heard so much about you and I want to, I have to ask,
where did you hear about me from who? Oh Lord. This is a small town.
I mean it just all over.
The telephones are ringing with my name pretty much. Okay. I gotta be nice.
Right? You're recording all this. I'm recording. You don't have to be nicer.
You can. Yeah. Oh, I'll be honest. I have no use for those people.
I didn't want them to take our tan. How long have you lived in Seneca?
Oh Gosh. About 36 37 years now.
And how many people live here? These guys, right in town maybe.
I don't know if even 22 yeah.
And we get talked about a lot.
I made wicked job put down a lot. Like what do you, excuse me.
Hi honey. I can't talk. Listen Simon's here.
Do you have anything you want me to ask him? Okay, bye. Bye. She,
I've been playing phone tag all day long. Okay. So you were saying they,
that people making fun of Seneca, what they do? They,
they make fun of Seneca quite a bit outside, you know,
unlike Authentica doesn't have anything, what are you still doing here?
And it's not like it used to be, I mean years and years ago,
this used to be at the neatest little town you'd everyone live in and then it
just, I dunno, it just went downhill.
Mm.
Yeah. Almost dying. I mean that's, that's the only way you can say it.
Sandy Hanson wanted to save the town, unofficial town historian.
This started back in 73,
I believe it was when it stopped being a division point.
So the trains no longer stopped here. So that did away with the three hotels,
the 24 hour cafe,
the man that had filling station pulled out in front of a semi at Mullen at
ended that business.
His brother had the shoe shop and he died of a heart attack setting.
They're working on is choose the lady that had the variety store tripped on a
kitten and broke her hip. That closed that
and uh,
[inaudible]
do you mind if we just wait until the train goes by? No.
anyhow, Seneca really started dying.
Yeah.
Presley get away from them. Okay. Well,
so I guess I'm here because I'm trying to talk to as many people as I can to
understand what happened with the whole vote to unincorporated
again, Savor Milli. It started out there was six horses.
They were up in mud up to their probably belly and I think,
um, one of them had to be put down because it was kicked.
This is how close they were together anyway. I mean, I'm an animal lover.
I wanted something done about it. Several of us did. So we had a meeting.
The board tried to tell him that's not sanitary,
Nancy Eisen and the rest of the safe Seneca three. We did discuss it. You know,
we've got to get the horses gone. That's the purpose of the, the ordinance.
But ed was not just that Judith Brown [inaudible] they wanted to get rid of all
the horses, all the cattle, all the chickens. That is ridiculous.
Happy chickens. But do you fly your chickens to, they run around town.
People are so afraid that their animals who were going to be taken away from
them and then eventually
the board members forbid people to have animals.
That was the just of it and so
more and more and more. The town got split.
There's a group of people here and a group of people here. Nobody gets along.
Nobody on the town board would speak anybody, which of course then that just,
man, I just yell at him louder.
There's certain people that I just get hand gesture.
One finger at hand gesture. Pretty much. Yeah. People said things like,
my dog doesn't want to be friends with your dog. It was awful.
You Terry, by chance, you know, can I have 20 minutes of your time?
I saw Terry Hartman who wanted to end the town. Yeah, this just got ugly.
They started taking pictures of people's places and put it on Facebook and say
how they didn't clean up their property and just public shaming people.
This was the same Seneca people that were posting this supposedly, you know,
there were aggressive comments. We did have the sheriff come up.
Did anyone tell you that it was just out of control? I mean,
what about a Xanax? You know, I took a lot of them during those years.
It was a very unhappy time and so finally people started going around with a
petition to get the unincorporated [inaudible] on the ballot.
We thought we will just unincorporated and even corporate unincorporated,
I'm incorporate our village and incorporate.
There are agitators in every grew.
Oh Wow.
Okay. That's me. That seems kind of like the nuclear option here, right?
Like we're just going to blow the whole thing up. Oh yes, absolutely.
[inaudible]
I think that sense of shared community was just slowly dissolving
year by year. Again, Matthew Hanson of the Omaha World Herald,
and it didn't have, it had probably to do with what was happening in Seneca,
but I also believe that I had to do what was happening in the United States.
So where did the idea that winning the argument is more important than the much
harder job of coming together and saying, okay, we disagree on this.
Let's find a, a solution to our problem.
[inaudible]
I'm having a little trouble figuring out what's about to happen.
Like how close is this?
The sense in the town was certainly that this thing was just a dead heat.
Really split right down the middle. Oh yeah, that's that close. And so, uh,
when we come back from break, Seneca goes to the voting booth and decides
this is Kim Eslinger calling from Bismark North Dakota.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
this is Kenneth Polaski from Plymouth, Michigan.
Radiolab is supported by TBS is new original comedy search party on TBS and
official selection at the 2016 south by southwest film festival.
Watch the mystery unravel as a lost soul.
And her group of friends search for a missing girl they barely even knew you can
binge the entire season of search party in one week, starting Monday,
November the 21st at 1110 central on TBS.
Hey guys, this is Alison calling from Luxembourg.
Radiolab is supported by rocket mortgage by quicken loans rocket mortgage.
Brings the mortgage process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process safely,
share your bank statements and pay stubs with the touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get a custom mortgage solution whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandanlsconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30
hello. Hello. My name is Simon. I think I sent you a letter a week.
We're not going to talk even even for five minutes. Nope, I don't want to.
You'll probably talk to the haters, but I'm done. Let the line dogs like,
okay. Thank you so much. Alright, bye. Goodbye.
All right, so that was a, that was Jacqueline licking,
who is the woman who circulated the petition and she a just refused to talk to
me.
I'm Robert Krulwich and I'm Simon Adler's is radio lab and Simon is with me.
Just
before the break you were saying Simon, the town is in Scott. Awful trouble.
Trouble.
Half the town was so upset with the town and the government and the people of
the town that they were circulating a petition
that would end the town itself. I mean, I got where they were upset,
but I certainly don't get the idea that the solution is to end this place that
has existed since 1888 this again is Matthew Hanson reporter for the Omaha World
Herald and it bugged me. W and y. Why did that bother you?
Because I'm from a small town.
I could imagine it happening to my town and I,
I can also empathize with the frustration of the people who wanted to keep it a
town. I mean you have to meet Sandy Hanson.
Will you show me a couple of your favorite artifacts you've got here?
Who operates a museum of Seneca History?
I want other people to know just how nice this place is.
You cannot go to her museum and not say, wait a second. This place has value.
This one I wish could talk. What?
We've got baseball jerseys here with the Asana, the Seneca baseball teams.
I got the uniforms. Even the socks, one pair of pants. Don't have the cap.
Santa Canada baseball team. Oh yes. Nolan all over the country.
Now this is the newspaper cutouts,
1860 these are pictures of family that lived here.
These are advertisements of people of the area.
You've gotta Send Seneca Centennial Hat? Yes.
And so people just send you stuff we went to. Is part of the concern here that
the history will be forgotten?
Yes, it is.
Because we have been a town for 120 some years.
So what is it? What does it mean to be a town?
What does it mean?
It means neighbors coming together for the good of each other.
When my husband died, he died in Texas. I brought his by a,
she's back at play and I'm just having a graveside service out there at cemetery
where all the time people wouldn't hear that they had a big meal prepared.
My Yard was mowed, the water was turned on,
everything was ready to go and it became a full service or what did that feel
like? It felt like home,
like the way you're supposed to feel, you know, warm and wanted
[inaudible].
You see they're talking about something that used to be, again,
Judith Brown who wanted to end the town.
They wanted to preserve it the way it was and I agree.
It used to be a lot of fun,
but that's true of any town up and down. This railroad will, if they,
if they're trying to preserve it, but then what are you trying to do?
You're just accepting that we're going downhill here. Know
I'm accepting that for I myself.
I can't do any better than this for myself as an aging woman.
I've only lived here 20 years, but I'm from here. My Mom,
my dad,
my cousins are all strung all over these hills and this grass,
you know. Anyway, I guess what I'm saying is to me it's heaven.
Like I don't care about my house falling down.
I'm 70 years old and I'm going to finish up my art supplies and die at the
respectable age of 96 and I do have enough art supplies
that putting up for years to do.
That was that the nerve that was being touched.
You're bad because you want to live this way. Yes.
These people saying we can be proud of our town,
we can make it hustle and bustle. So if they're saying that, then you're saying,
no, we can be proud of just the way it is now. Yeah. See.
Okay. So how, when did you first hear about the petition going around?
Oh Gosh. Um, again, Millie from the safe Seneca side,
I think the same day it was going around, I heard about it. And how,
how did you feel in that moment? It was horrible. It really was. It was just,
it was more than frustrating.
It was just like somebody punches you in the gut and she lets all the air out,
you know? It's just,
it's just sad.
Mostly it just seemed like if we could get rid of this unbelievable piece of
bureaucracy, then we could just live here.
So finally, if the unincorporated,
it got on the ballot at the regular election where you do the senators and all
that, we add a special ballot for Seneca where we voted for the town.
And would it or would it not be unincorporated?
What did you feel when you were going to that to vote for you?
I don't remember feeling anything except I've got to get in there and vote.
If you don't mind just telling me how you voted. Oh, I voted to unincorporated.
I voted to keep the town incorporated. I have loaded ton incorporate.
I voted to keep the town and then she said, okay,
okay, that's the last Seneca ballot shoes on or she's that she's on
Jackie. Severe Sabre.
So just because I don't think I've had anybody explained this to me yet.
Can you explain the night of the election and what actually happened?
Well, you know we have Internet access,
so we were watching the election results on the Internet to see how it came out
and who is we are there were, I don't remember, four or five of us,
six of us maybe. I'm not sure who all was there.
So what would you like refreshing the page over and over again?
How did that work? No, we knew about what time they'd be on. You know,
we gave them an hour or so and we logged on and saw it.
We saw that the village was unincorporated.
It was by one vote.
[inaudible] it was 15 to 16 we lost our town.
Sandy Hanson again. Hello. What was that looking like?
I can't say it on the radio. So what was lost?
Well, the day after they decided to abolish a town,
the sheriff come down with them.
I don't know what they thought we were going to shoot them off but guns or what?
But the sheriff came down, they took the grater,
they took the tractor that for took our snowplow and we no longer have our
street maintenance, our lights, maybe our identity. I don't know.
We never had much here, but we didn't ask for much. I mean we lost,
we lost.
So will be taken off at the map and if it isn't on the map where they can look
it up, there ain't nobody knows it's there.
I cried. But I mean it hurts.
Dancey ice him again cause I've been here since my third grade year.
People are moving away and Jackie's severe. I'm myself, I'm ready to go.
We're all ready to leave. We don't have anybody. There's been,
nobody moved here since nobody.
It sounds like you're saying the future is gone. I wouldn't say it's gone,
but I would say it's very, very limited and unlikely. Yes,
I have voted done incorporate
again, Terry Hartman,
but I love this town and I think the people who voted to unincorporated are the
people who wanted to keep things the way they were. We didn't want to change.
I know everything has to change, but,
but I didn't know what else to stop dividing. You know,
this is my hometown too. I don't know how to explain it. It,
it just got so ugly and out of hand and some of the members of the village board
were just crazy, but the town board was just three members.
Millie,
they have to do really what the majority of the town wants to do.
Otherwise we can get rid of them. So you believe in the democracy of Seneca,
I believe in democracy. Does that make me an idiot?
I mean, I live in hope, you know,
[inaudible]
it just,
it really felt like Seneca had lost something essential when we're talking about
basic American democracy again, Matthew Hanson of the Omaha World Herald.
And it worried me to that and part
because I could feel that and still feel that happening on a national level that
the kind of a just complete lack of conversation around shared values or a
compromise.
I've got a smoke mourn and drink more and one that's time.
Okay. Judith Brown. So, um,
okay. Can I, can I tell you what I, what I hear here,
maybe the strongest argument for keeping Seneca a town on the books is that then
there was some sort of framework to force those two communities within the town
to be together and to think together. And with that now gone,
there is now no communication, no compromise, nope.
So none of those people had anything to do with this before except it
continually criticized how we were.
So we couldn't compromise with these people. They were not rational.
All rationality was gone by then.
And what's going to happen with this next election.
But America is full of diverse opinions and it has managed to work.
And I guess if we take what happened here,
and if we apply that model to the rest of the United States, like if not a town,
then what?
Um, we have the county,
we have the state and the little town without those hateful people in it is
really quite lovely. But it's not a town anymore.
I don't know why you think that officially. Right.
But it is a town. Here we are.
I'm going to live here until I die.
And so it was rose and Harry until some woman lands him.
So you would say that even though on the books, Seneca no longer exists.
Seneca is still exists. Yest and we're still two tribes.